well laziness impatience and hubris
these originated as sort of a joke in
the first edition of what we call the
camel book programming Perl and in a
sense that they are the three virtues of
programmer a lazy person will try always
find some way to do something they'll
always be looking for ways of doing
something faster more efficiently and if
you really want to you know control the
world that's a really sort of hubristic
notion you know excessive pride the
thing that that's at that that Zeus zaps
you for having but it really was sort of
a joke in the Japanese edition of the
the translated edition of the the camel
book they actually had to put laziness
in patience and hubris this is a joke
because they felt that they would take
it seriously
so laziness really it's what makes a
good programmer is is much more than
those three things if if you've either
read the Lord of the Rings or seen seen
the movies and you know about hobbits
and hobbits manifest many of the virtues
that you need is a programmer you need
to you know you need to have persistence
when the going gets rough to keep
slogging through a kind of you know
innate stubbornness in a happy way not
in a mean way you have to be smart
enough to how your wit your enemies
occasionally you know and you have to
okay you have to be able to be social
you have to be able to deal with a group
your team members some of which are like
you there other hobbits some of which
are elves and dwarves or even men and I
think very differently from you so you
have to be able to contribute your part
as a hobbit but also be able to
understand other things so the day is
long past when when most programming is
done individually almost all programming
is done in teams and so you need to be
literate in a sense of The Hobbit sense
of knowing your letters you have to be
able to read documentation you have to
be able to be able to write
documentation that others can understand
but mostly you have to be just slightly
insane in the way that hobbits are where
they can in view the long term you know
the goal is to get back to your comfy
burrow and and view all the everything
between here and there at the same time
forget about all that and just deal with
the problem you have at hand I have this
problem so you know when you're in more
concrete terms on a on a computer you're
telling it to do various things by name
and it's going off of doing those you
have to simultaneously be aware of what
it's doing down underneath but if you're
always aware of everything is doing you
going really nuts so you also have to be
able to shut that out and and work on
the high level abstraction and doing
though both of those simultaneously
gives the best result in programming if
you ignore either one of those you end
up messing up so that's what you really
need and so like a hobbit laziness a
hobbit is is lazy in a very industrious
way and a hobbit is impatient in a very
patient way
and a hobbit is is proud in a very
humble way it sort of seems like
contradictions but to the extent that
you can increase your dynamic range on
all of those you'll be a better
programmer